It's almost time to go but before we do,
we love to leave you with a little something
to take to go and we call it The Doggy Bag.
(light tones)
(Ross growling and barking)
There he goes.
And today it's a handy dandy little tip care of TikTok.
Ross, you know when you wanna wrap a towel
around your waist, like after a shower at the pool?
Well actually, I know you rock it like a serious,
amazing caftan, one that you made personally.
Yeah, it's true.
But then it keeps like falling off
and the towel--
Yeah, I can never figure out how they do that.
People do it so it stays on tight.
Okay, well this comes from Brayden Singley,
a choreographer and dancer, and apparently towel genius.
Take a look.
What if you tuck the excess underneath?
You're invincible.
Murderer in the shower?
(door ratting)
Run away.
(hosts laughing)
Okay, so wait, what did he do there?
Show me.
Okay, you...
Does anyone else do this?
I mean, I feel like this is common knowledge.
I do it like this and it just falls off.
Well, that's why because you gotta wrap it here
and then you fold it over once
and sometimes I'll even fold it over twice
because then you're just like, I don't know.
I feel like I'm in "The Blue Lagoon".
I've got my loin cloth, but I'm so short.
(audience laughing)
Why is mine so short though?
Drew, this is not, look at this.
That's not a cute look.
Someone whistled.
(audience laughing)
Do not pity me.
(audience applauding)
Do not.
Look, this is not a cute look.
I don't know, Rossy.
I think you look pretty cute.
I would tell you.
You would?
I believe you.
Of course I would.
Well, you don't look cute, take it off.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Well, I'm telling you though it does do the trick.
And especially if you're like swimming,
I do that because I have a bathing suit on the top.
I don't swim topless, unless I'm alone.
It's really staying though.
Look, I'm jumping, it's not going anywhere.
Okay, I'm gonna work on mine, it wasn't cute.
You keep talking.
All right, well thank you so much
to our guests here in the audience today.
And everybody watching at home.
(audience cheering and applauding)
We're so honored you spent time with us.
We hope you have a fantastic day
and we hope you take all of this with you.
(upbeat music)